we want to talk about that one weather
alert there's just one right now that
flash flood warning
has been extended until midnight oracle
talked about that and this
is all the issues all of them we had
with that storm that hit that area
that's all on our website and social
media if you want to check that out
look at the latest on that storm that
was really hitting
and impacting that area now winding down
not as intense as earlier but the rain
still coming down you saw oracle's live
shot
zooming out our area did get some
rainfall right around that eight o'clock
hour like we talked about
nothing severe though showers came
through but the focus of that energy was
really
out into northeast clark county right
now we're clear of the showers
unfortunately
but there's still some showers around
the region and specifically up in the
northeast part of the valley
here's the other cool part those gusty
winds we had earlier
those have decreased but look at the
temperatures right now that rain cooled
air i talked about earlier
76 in las vegas right now 74 in
henderson 79 for nellis and same for
north las vegas it feels nice out there
could we see more storms in the forecast
for tomorrow i'll pinpoint when
that's all coming up in your most
accurate forecast